how's it going as my yeah anyway welcome
to oculus rift videos and I'm pretty
damn excited so let's do it
so someone made the original Zelda oh my
god wait sorry alright
we have Zelda Legend of Zelda original
friend yes 1986 is that long ago huh oh
god this is so crazy this is really
[ __ ] cool alright let's go down whoa
oh god it's dangerous to go alone take
this kanima's it's so [ __ ] cool I
cannot explain this I just can't
Oh got him what whoa
take that and that and they it and they
it don't think you can escape from my oh
gotta get them rubies broccoli I have
not played this in forever and it's so
weird to re-experience in the oculus
bang I'm genuinely freaked out oh god oh
god don't do that I like my sword
it looks like I'm pointing the finger
whoa what oh my god get the car yeah oh
god I gotta fight them all it's like
Pokemon but not really I don't know why
I keep saying that I use slimy blobs
take the bomb how's my health oh god I
didn't even know Oh God shape up I can't
die now [ __ ] no there we go I'm better
now I didn't pay attention to my life
that's why
it's kind of like real life for me
actually I never pay attention to
anything except my beautiful looks and
my luscious eyebrows let's be honest
they are pretty luscious this is a lot
easier on the oculus cuz I can aim
whatever the [ __ ] I want
nice skirts where did you get them
forever 21 God my life is down take the
BAM gay get the campus oh no it's a trap
oh god I am awful all right very cool
experience I def you have an oculus you
gotta check this one out next one it's
called dilash dilution I don't know
anything about it it's not supposed to
be our game I hope you better not be
[ __ ] with me here if this is a horror
game I'm quitting it I'm not doing
harder today instructions oh [ __ ] me run
why would I need to run Oh God
you lied didn't you if I see one little
monster I swear to God
alright what do we get here oh nice
mr. face huh great name I thought that
was the monster in the meat already
local girl mysteriously disappeared she
probably hung out with that mr. face guy
I would assume maybe she shouldn't have
done that [ __ ] what do I know about life
in jail [ __ ] me it's [ __ ] dark they
said this was a thriller I am NOT very
thrilled hey putz don't worry it's
nothing personal
oh [ __ ] me what's going on down here
make fun
you [ __ ] line so tired of [ __ ] her
again I swear to [ __ ] god
so [ __ ] all these horror ones we're
gonna play Nikolas which is about cats
and how you cuddle dead I love cats
hey kitties oh you so Kelly oh my god
they suck you come here another one
Oh another more wait I can I can sponder
myself this is amazing it's the happiest
day of my life
all right cats I got a bowl for you get
it oh my god so cute oh my god I'm dying
give it to me
oh thanks all right take it
oh [ __ ] uh subject
alright everyone on the couch oh Jesus
Christ you guys are good I give you that
you guys are really [ __ ] good that
guy not so good Axl Axl you're in the
way
all right you guys like this ha I'm not
my face aah oh my god what I am being
smothered by kitty cats
this is the happiest day of my life it's
the Sun is so kawaii overload oh my god
now replaces with a dick and we got
something completely different
I'm not being perfect I'm just [ __ ]
saying I would not be surprised if
someone if one horny developer in Japan
does that I'm just saying it's ok
so kill alright alright this one is the
matrix how [ __ ] cool is that like a
dream come true let's test it out what
what weapons uh-huh training simulation
okay anything porn I don't how do you
define hey there you are
if you're talking about what you can
feel what you can smell ya taste and see
then real is simply electrical signals
interpreted by your brain holy [ __ ]
you're right can we get to the guns part
guns oh do you know what the world as it
was at the end of the 20th century
uh-huh don't remember being that that's
bad now only as part of a neural
interactive simulation uh-huh that we
call the matrix whatever you whatever
floats your boat man I'll be going now
hey what are you doing up there hi I'm
not I'm not a fan of this place don't do
horror stuff please I played this one
subtle I selected this one not for scary
some okay so ripped a miracle guns guns
lots of them lot yes bring it on bring
it on
oh yeah I'll have that one in that I
never done anything like this I want to
see that movie now so bad that was it
that was a very basic but very [ __ ]
cold man
very [ __ ] cold lane last but not
least snow drift let's do this I can
choose between normal or intense intense
okay well it's duty ish we're going in
the snow brows
whoo hey oh my god I'm going what what
is happening I'm going like all the kids
do down the slopes not your friends now
french fries hamburgers french fries
hamburgers all the french fries all the
french fries oh god I can do tricks and
[ __ ] oh my god that is amazing I'm
actually pretty good skiing look at this
[ __ ]
whoa don't bother ow oh I think I made
it I made it I don't know how haha
get that blue cloud oh no oh God an
avalanche no it's just me being awesome
front flip wow wow wow what is happening
I just broke my neck that's fine don't
worry about it press you didn't hurt a
little bit let's get this snowflake I
think that's what it is
ugliest snowflake ever abbess we're
going through the APIs oh oh oh oh my
craft ow ow my face I now look like
Michael Jackson [ __ ] actually that's
probably a good thing I bet I could make
millions in printer predation in that's
a word I guess my skiing is a little
wobbly here whoa where Oh God I made it
haha this is amazing alright get some
speed get some speed girl double
backflip while I wait across the sky
whoa oh wow this is so cool don't crash
into the trees oh god oh god oh god I
regret nothing I gray out I went through
it I don't know how this is possible
ow ha ha ha oh my god it would be funny
if this was like it's free that game ski
free and all the sudden this Yeti will
just come up and eat you happy that
would be hilarious here we go this is
the exit were a little wobbly can we
make it what is that out she's probably
not going to yeah we're dead in France
amazing amazing I was a lot of fun I
hope you had fun I had a lot of fun
dress
you bring out with me and thank you for
watching me play uh and also thanks for
leaving like a lot of things here I
don't know why I'm so [ __ ]
appreciated you're all right all right
you're all right don't get cocky now
sales and pres love you